was geht ab hier ist euer cranio wir
spielen heute ein ründchen get down on
it gets ghana-spiel das ganze mit sturm
mache jetzt willkommen zum video mit dem
urkomischen anfang seit youtube youtube
und die standard schneide ich weiß doch
heutzutage wird da gefragt jeder wie es
dem anderen geht ja und da war die
krasse standard damals als ich das dich
und stege gefragt habe habt ihr mich
ausgedacht wie gar nicht doch sie
beweismaterialien für meine folge glaube
ich nicht videos davon vier jahren sind
wir gerade dem video jetzt gar dass ein
live stream
er sagt mir doch mal bescheid warum gott
ja wahrscheinlich so gerade eben noch
dick über lucas mutter gerettet
aber das war gleich ein paar reisen spaß
leute ist es gar kein deutsch
es ist nämlich ein video das ihr video
stream heute in der schule mein handy
weggenommen bekommen ernst ja es ist
sehr traurig folge blieb mit allem mit
direktor gesagt dass mein job sagt
meinen job ich hab' ich hab gesagt
überhaupt irgendwie noch telefonate
wichtige mäßig nur und mein sohn schon
recht dürfen wir einhalten
aber die waren halt davor voll böse war
zudem macht er zielgenau unfreundlich
aber sachlich und freundlich
ich habe wurde nicht beleidigend also
ich habe nicht gesagt du [ __ ]
sondern nicht abziehen so und gesagt ich
glaube nicht dass sich diese einstellung
als lehrer geeignet sind so mäßig weil
er halt gesagt hat dabei so gemeint ja
hier dafür die herausgabe von meinem
besitz und eigentum verlangen und dann
hat es auch nur schurig nicht peinlich
dass du das nicht weiß dass er wenn sie
es peinlich finden dass das schüler was
nicht wissen sollten sie vielleicht kein
lehrer werden aber ist dass er ein gutes
argument muss man bis zum 6 und dann
waren wir aber alle beleidigt
eingeschnappt und dann habe ich mein
handy bekommt morgen kriegen es wieder
freunde dann kann ich wieder
probier s mal den twitter account da hat
er erstmal was geht redet heute schon
ruiniert elektro 11freunde also live
legend für euch ihr könnt euch
grundsätzlich entscheiden ob ihr ein
verweis wollt oder euer handy ab könnte
die herausgabe verweigert
sobald dann aber heraus gegeben habt
habt ihr problem also gebt niemals wenn
ihr es wenn ihr in verweist dafür in
kauf nehmen wollt euer handy ab gewonnen
er kratzt das nicht schnell
ja das sind die live lessons hiervon
ecke von edgar von cramm esse ich muss
glaube ich niemanden handy abgeben
ich musste das auch jetzt heute das
erste mal tatsächlich vor lächerliche
allerdings angelegt man meiner
französischlehrerin weil die halt immer
gegen jungs war es die die machte keine
jungs einfach und gewann halt immer nur
zu dritt im französischunterricht hat
und irgendwann das war aber auch die
lehrerinnen die mir gezeigt hat dass
deshalb auch nur menschen sind und ich
halt auch meine meinung ganz normal
sagen dafür was nicht passt wie das wild
lehrer ja also das war davor immer
dieses ohne lehrer volk über menschen
und man darf nichts böses sagen und so
geschichten und immer schön sachlich
bleiben freunde dann können
genau das habe ich dann halt auch
irgendwann mal gemacht hatte die mir
nämlich dann muss ich meine arbeit
korrigieren das weiß ich noch das waren
keine ahnung drei din a4 seiten oder so
was hab ich dann in zusammenarbeit mit
einer oder meiner nachhilfelehrerin die
die auf kante tatsächlich weil also
möchte ich mir einfach irgendwann dann
mal nach einem jahr wo es mittelmäßig
gut bis schlecht lief sagt habe ja
kommen
unsere nachbarin ist französisch
lehrerin dann gehe ich zu der halt und
die hatten wir dann halt nachhilfe
gegeben also die wahl schon rente und
damit meine ich halt ja natürlich habe
ich die arbeit berichtigt in der fm4
hatte weil ich wie soll ich denn machen
sonst ist ihr habt das so schnell voll
schlecht gemacht und wenn ich das
genauso wir mussten das dann immer noch
mehr also mussten mehr schreiben wenn
wir unter nach vier hatten was die regel
wurde übrigens eingeführt als alle vier
jungs in der klasse unter vier stunden
also kein scheiß jetzt da war gab es das
nicht und nur für die arbeit danach
nicht mehr weil dann
seine zwei hatte keine ahnung und dann
bin ich ja nur vorne gegangen da meinte
sie ja von wegen
los geht es mit einer nachhilfe gemacht
und ich sehe da eine zeit form die wir
im unterricht noch nicht durchgenommen
haben
dementsprechend will ich noch mal dass
du nach hause gehst und den kompletten
text das komplett andere schreibt weil
wir diese zeit vorm einfach noch nicht
geübt haben
der halt gesagt find ich total dumm
das werde ich nicht machen so nach dem
motto dann habe ich mich damit der
angelegten aber nicht so viel versteht
auch nicht warum sie mich irgendwie an
angreifen müssen oder anschreiben weil
es ist einfach keine logische begründung
für mich und dementsprechend werde ich
das auch nicht machen und dann ja hatte
mich das total zusammen gepfiffen die
ganze zeit war echt nicht so naiv muss
schon sagen aber sehr stark wert was
respekt von der klasse der branche gut
wie ich meine hier da leider war ich
dabei schon älter ich finde es sei
lächerlich dass die einem 18 jährigen
soll das handy wegnehmen weil ich leicht
auf 17 oder so glaube ich habe endlich
wahr einer zwischen stunde einfach nur
kurz am handy und wenn uns ein video
angeschaut
ein kollege von mir wir waren aber auch
eine feiern und er hat eine wette
verloren hatten fans bekommt und dieses
video angeschaut dann hat sie voll
wie gut ist er in die krippe das bin ich
wie kannst du so gut sein soll noch ganz
einfach ich mein ganzes geld ausgegeben
500 callcenters ich habe auch 500 auf
java ein fachmann die rüstung kaufen
das kostet ja ich glaub 400 oder ganze
manstein schreibt nehmen und deren
tradition so viele coins ich bin gerade
rausgeflogen ist meine erste runde
gestern übrigens freunde sondern du bist
auch ausgegangen dass gut
deshalb wollen dass ich schlecht war wie
hast du noch mal ich bin
gar nicht von kevin garnett ethernet poe
war los du bist gar nicht wo du bist bin
ich doch versteht sein bruder nick
christiane paul hannes wie gar nicht
verstehst du für 108 und einheiten feuer
schwert das ist sehr gemein ungefähr
erschwert
ja das ist ein starkes feuer schwer
freunde dieser spielmodus es lustig ich
werde ihn perfektionieren und dann
werden wir sehen wenn ich gut bin eins
wert als scheiße ich tanze hier mal ein
getöteter netze direkt die dir sachen
bekommen von dem ja aber wie soll ich
ihn töten wenn ich nur bayerisch und
lehre habe volkow hast du auch mal
gewonnen
ein parcours wie nie aber ich sammle die
ganze blöcke
ich glaube das war mein problem ich habe
ich gar keine kontakte gesammelt
doch so ganz aber auch wenn er untergeht
kriegst du glaub ich immer 150 oder so
wenn du gewinnst aber durch sehr einmal
gewonnen auch dort ist auch eigentlich
fast genauso viel wie ich habe mich
folgen du bist voll apropos sie ich
verstehe es auch gar nicht also ich bin
runter kommen lief relativ gut aber dann
war es mir dann nicht mehr so da ist
eine testmaschine ja der hat mich auch
ermordet oder zu einer angel weit ist
das so eine dings sage hier
damit können so ziehen um so was sogar
durch ganz schlechte erfahrungen mit von
community cash machine aktuell ist will
weil ich als jörg beck & fire aspect der
einer kapstadt steht er mir
vorgeschlagen
respekt ist zum weglaufen
ja ich habe noch einiges an leben
eigentlich stark dann könntest du schon
bei den letzten beiden rennen hatte eine
wunderschöne doch was wenn jetzt erst
mal bitten wollen ohne würde ich auch
hier ihr spectator its best das habe ich
schon seit 3000 jahren ich mache das
hier anders was zu eines begleitet habe
freunde ich hoffe das ist ja auch ein
erst eine neue runde hier das allererste
mal einen euro sonst immer dieselbe
coach tommy rasiere ihn quasi erst mal
wieder super merkwürdig hin und her
large und müssen dann mein equipment
hier protection hose gemacht
ghosting ko sagt nein wenn man nur
ghosting dauer sagt dann esse ich kein
rohes den ok freude
die heutige lebens lektion ist lasst
euch nicht von euren sogenannten
respektperson die laune verderben
zu unrecht wie schön was wollen wir
okay leute damals